عندما استلقت ويندي ويليامز مقعدها على
متن رحلة تابعة لشركة الخطوط الجوية الأمريكية ، كانت لديها
فكرة بسيطة عن المشكلة التي كانت
مخبأة ،
قالت إنها كانت عائدة من
محفل المعلمين عندما سألها الرجل
الجالس خلفها عما إذا كانت
ستعيد مقعدها إلى الأمام بينما هو يأكل
وجبته تقول ويليامز إنها فعلت ذلك
وأنها تراجعت مرة أخرى فقط عندما
انتهى من تناول الطعام ، لكن ويليام يقول إن الرجل
بدأ يلكم مقعدها مرارًا وتكرارًا
لأن الفيديو يظهر أن CNN غير قادرة على
الوصول إلى الرجل في الفيديو الفيروسي للتعليق
على الاتكاء أو عدم القيام بذلك.  تتكئ هذه ليست
المرة الأولى التي يتم فيها طرح المشكلة
في الأرباع
الاقتصادية القريبة في عام 2014 ، حيث اضطرت رحلة طيران يونايتد إيرلاينز
إلى التحويل عندما
دخل راكبان في مشاجرة حول
أداة تسمى مدافع الركبة ، حيث
اخترع الجهاز IRA Goldman في  2003 الفكرة
هي منع المقعد أمامك
من الاستلقاء ، أخبرتني جولدمان أن الأمر كله
يتعلق بموافقة الركاب إذا اشتريت
تذكرة اقتصادية وهذه المساحة
الكبيرة  هي المساحة التي أحصل عليها ، لكنني لا أوافق
عندما أصعد على متن طائرة لأقول بالتأكيد
تعال وضربني على ركبتي ، وبالتالي
فإن عالم السفر يضج مرة أخرى
بمسألة إمالة المقاعد في الدرجة
الاقتصادية وما هو  الشيء الصحيح الذي
يجب فعله مع حشر شركات الطيران في المزيد من المقاعد
لتناسب المزيد من الركاب الذين
سيتعين عليهم التعامل مع عواقب
تراجع تصميمهم في CNN New York